Jacob now remembers coming to seek
refuge in this camp for the internally
displaced people in Juba it's next to
the United Nations base so he feels safe
here he was a Schoolboy back in 2013
soon after war broke out he's now 25
years old with Children of his own he
hasn't been able to go back home because
of violence in parts of South Sudan to
us as idps here we are lacking a lot of
things especially put we stayed without
food for five months
or the distribution start
last yesterday two days back
and there's also bad news about it
that the food is going to last only for
six months then after six months there
will be no food according to the United
Nations there are more than 2 million
internally displaced people in South
Sudan and another 2.3 million have fled
the country as refugees famine was
briefly declared in some regions in
2017. more than two-thirds of the
population now need humanitarian Aid
because of conflict and natural
disasters
the 2018 peace deal stopped the worst of
the fighting but parts of the agreement
including the deployment of a reunified
national Army have not been implemented
and that's why some people say they
don't feel safe returning home
the head of the Catholic Church Pope
Francis along with leaders of the
Anglican and Scottish Presbyterian
churches have voiced concerns about the
government's slow progress in
implementing the 2018 peace deal they've
been delayed in holding elections and
reports of violence in some areas
Civil Society groups say a lack of
political will and personal differences
between politicians in South Sudan is
the problem
so until they are able to say enough is
enough to our personal problems and we
cannot use our personal differences to
subject the country to suffer in the way
we are suffering now this country we
can't deliver them we can deliver this
country from violence to Peace So the
leaders need to forget their personal
problems the church has a lot of
influence in South Sudan which is a
predominantly Christian country many
here hope this historic visit puts
pressure on politicians to do better and
work towards peace and Reconciliation